they found it in the freezing mountains  of the yukon the scp foundation an  organization dedicated to finding and  containing supernatural objects and  entities sent in two attack helicopters  to collect it a huge humanoid creature  with freakishly long legs and arms as  the soldiers approached it the monster  turned and they saw its face it was all  over in an instant the beast went  berserk and killed everyone no level of  firepower was able to stop it and that's  because when someone sees the face of  scp-096  also known as the shy guy nothing can  stop it the monster kills anyone who  sees its face without fail even if you  see a photo of its ugly mug you're  effectively doomed it's one of the  scariest and most infamous beasts  contained by the scp foundation and if  you want to live a full life make sure  to keep it out of your sight or you'll  end up between its sights